a mother's grief heard across Iran after
the death of her daughter in police
custody in Tehran on September 16th
22 year old Masa amini was in the
capital with her brother visiting
relatives when she was detained by the
morality police three days earlier she
was accused of not properly wearing the
mandatory headscarf she was from
Kurdistan Province home to Iran's
Kurdish minority the police released the
security camera footage which they say
shows Masa arriving at a facility where
she was to go through what's called a
re-education class on the religious
benefits of wearing the headscar the
official autopsy report and subsequent
investigation launched by the government
alleged Massa had a pre-existing health
condition and suffered heart attack
while in police custody her family says
this is not true and accused the
morality police of beating her while in
custody
scenes like these followed her death and
sparked Nationwide protests driven by
women who demand an end to restrictive
dress rules in the country those who
backed the existing laws were allowed to
gather in Tehran to show their support
for the government while the president
was quick to address the issue in a live
televised interview
I told her family that this news was
shocking not just for me but for every
Iranian criticism and Dialogue on
various issues have a place in the
Constitution and can help us in the
decision-making process but the
distinction between protest and Riot
should be defined earlier this month
president raisi visited an all-female
University in Tehran where he praised
the movements of women in the field of
Academia simultaneously this was
happening outside the building where the
president was speaking
chanting Gracie get lost these
University students made their demands
clear
this Iranian MP warns without some
systematic reforms there could be
further consequences
it was due to the performance of the
system that she passed away they have to
express regret and apologize and revise
their methods the unrest that's followed
Masa amini's death has resulted in a
number of deaths including both
demonstrators and security officials
this is the area where Iran's morality
police arrested NASA amini on a Tuesday
afternoon since then they haven't been
seen much in the city whatever happens
next year regardless of which version of
events people believe it is clear that
masaamini's death has changed this
country
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Tehran